I am Nicholas B i'm with matt welch
we're doing ask a libertarian 2012 to
celebrate the publication of the
paperback edition of our book the
Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America pre-order it at your
favorite bookstore online next question
comes from salio of youtube did rand
paul compromised his principles by
endorsing Mitt Romney was endorsing
Romney a compromise or just plain smart
in order to further Rand Paul's
libertarian agenda and congressman I
think it's obvious by watching what they
do and then talking to people who are
surrounding Ron Paul that central to
their efforts this year have been
positioning Rand Paul to be able to run
for president either as a Republican
standard-bearer or as a primary
challenger to Mitt Romney in 2016 Ron
Paul certainly has been trying to set up
this run in such a way so that rands
career which has been pretty interesting
so far is not hobbled within the
Republican Party so I see rands
endorsement which came only after
basically Mitt Romney was mathematically
guaranteed to be the nominee of the
Republican Party I see that is totally
in step with that and it's pretty
interesting and I think an omelette a
little bit funny how many people who are
fervent fans of rampal are kind of
accusing random stabbing Ron in the back
look they've lived together for kind of
a long time they hang out they consult
with one another I think this is
perfectly in keeping with Rand trying to
build a little block within the
Republican Party right now that actually
cares about such things as the Fourth
Amendment which the republican party
hasn't really cared about for a long
time yeah Rand Paul is arguably the most
libertarian member of Congress even more
so than his father he's not perfect but
you know he's pretty damn good and I
find it i'm not planning on voting for
the republican candidate but Rand Paul
and Ron Paul are Republicans you know in
the political arena and I think this is
going to help libertarians have more of
an ear of Mitt Romney and we'll be here
all day ask a libertarian come on back
you